ladies and gentlemen tomorrow's
headlines will be made here tonight
around the world this is news from the
motion picture capital of the world
Oldsmobile presents with pride the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences 26th annual Academy Awards
this is the city called Hollywood the
heart of a community dedicated to the
manufacturer of dreams and tonight is
the night dreams come true for some of
Hollywood's citizens this is movie
town's election night the final game of
the World Series the running of the
Derby the Rose Bowl this is Academy
Awards night the people who make your
movies are gathered to honor the
distinguished achievements of their own
during the year just past and through
the wonders of television
you too are approaching the scene of the
big payoff
this is Hollywood's glittering hour and
you the audience who make it all
possible are welcome you are in the
Pantages Theatre a few steps from the
corner of Hollywood and Vine in a few
moments you will take a giant step
across the continent to New York City
where more Award winners of the past and
some of tonight's nominees are gathering
and now here is the award-winning song
lullaby of Broadway played by the
Academy Awards orchestra Andre Previn
conducting
Oh
only us can attract the star-spangled
crowd such as this seated in this
sellout audience tonight our actors and
actresses whose names are household
words whose faces are known wherever the
silvery screen or the printed page are a
part of life here also are the artists
and technicians who have made these
stars but they are tonight all of them
share a common emotion with you and me
suspense we are not alone there are
others waving with excitement in New
York City here they are this is the NBC
Center Theatre in New York you see
anyone you recognize in this audience so
such familiar persons is
this is Fred Allen Steve Allen
being a hard several of tonight's
nominees are on their way there from
professional chores in Broadway theaters
we'll come back and meet them later
right now
let's flip the switch again and go back
at the Hollywood Hollywood police
cooperate with the industry in blocking
off special traffic lanes and handling
the crowds who turn out in such force
shall we follow them into the theater
all right New York London Paris Sydney
Rio Hong Kong the 26th annual Academy
Awards show is underway
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences
mr. Charles Brackett
general members of the Academy yes
friends everywhere last year on this
stage and over these channels we
celebrated a birthday with that backward
glance everyone gives when the big dial
has ticked off a quarter of a century we
were 25 the industry was 50 we felt fine
but there were certain lung folk who
were afraid that the motion picture
industry and all its arts and sciences
hadn't much longer to live the audience
they said it drifted away tonight we
celebrate a single year 1953 we
celebrated exultant life as a year of
rebirth
revitalization new techniques new
dimensions as to the audience it hasn't
drifted back it has surged back but with
a new look a more knowing eye and
insistence on showmanship a demand for
balance perfection in every department
of picture making it seems all they're
cantankerous hearts desired with great
pictures
well they got them this makes for a
magnificent race tonight such a race of
champion against champion as the Academy
has never put on in choosing our master
of ceremonies however the Academy didn't
wish to ignore its glorious past so we
chose a veteran player for 17 years he's
kicked around in front of those cameras
ladies and gentlemen mr. Donald O'Connor
now I'm gonna have my wheelchair pick me
up at 12 will you know let's say I have
that
hello ladies gentlemen I want to say how
wonderful it is to be here well I tell
you I really didn't think I was going to
be the master of ceremonies tonight I
really didn't I really did I thought I
thought I was going to be the star this
is your life
well anyway welcome to this is your
Oscar I tell you last year I saw the I
saw all the awards being given away and
I really think I think last year if I'd
been here there was one part I should
have played and I think I would have won
an Oscar myself the picture I was
supposed to do was the picture that Burt
Lancaster did and worked with Shirley
booth I was come back to achievement of
course he got the part in that I you
know politics but anyway to be here this
year I'm so happy because I'm so happy
to be the master ceremonies for this
exciting evening because it fills me
with well I I mean it I feel like well I
well I'm terrified but anyway on with
the reading of the will
1953 certainly was a big year for
Hollywood at least it was a wide year
and there are more improvements to come
because I and us all over the world are
hard at work perfecting new devices in
France French scientists are working on
a rocket ship that will take movies to
the moon on Russian scientists are
working on a ship that will take them
out of Russia this thing's going can you
hear me
I should have memorized it again treated
but I tell you I tell you I went you
know it wasn't all work for producers
last year however I went to a party at a
producers house and he had a big tub of
champagne the way we stood around
ducking for caviar and later everyone
got up and entertained Bob Hope did a
Crosby imitation he filled his mouth
with crushed ice sang white Christmas
and snowed on the guests well outside
tonight is the most romantic night of
the year and sharing it with us is a
glamorous group gathered in the NBC
Center Theater in New York City New York
so let's go there now and meet our East
Coast master of ceremonies a two-time
Oscar winner mr. Frederick Marge
thank you Thank You Donald
friends yes this is a dramatic night in
New York - of course
this is a dramatic season here
springtime Central Park is all green
flowers are bursting in the flame
delicatessen stores are changing over to
summer weight salami and it's beautiful
and I may say Donald you are doing a
beautiful job tonight why that be shame
danke Schoen I I didn't know you spoke
German Donna well just a few words you
see when I was a kid we had a duck soon
well I hope you kept him I understand
zanuck wants to remake the Rin Tin Tin
pictures in CinemaScope okay I give up
look before before we get on with the
Academy Awards I'd like to ask you a
question mr. March what's this mr.
routine were all one big happy family
Donald
well okay dad tell me something yes son
uh what are you doing in New York just
they're just a couple of a couple of
weeks ago you're out here making a
picture well I uh I have a television
deal offered me here Donald so I came
east to discuss it well I can understand
that and believe me it was a tough
decision to make
yeah what did you decide well I figured
this way I have been on Broadway and
radio and pictures I can afford it so I
bought the set
well just in time to tonight it turning
all that we'll all crowd around for a
musical message from a good friend of
the Academy it's an old song that goes
something like this
come away with me Lucille in my Mario's
'mobile this is Oscars biggest night
Hollywood is shining here is one with
star Rafi insist our firewalls moby
irresistible is convertible mr. Thomas
good evening everyone I'm Paul Douglas
and on behalf of all mobile welcome to
this the 26th annual presentation of the
Academy Awards now speaking Feroze
Mobile is very easy and quite natural to
me because I'm an Oldsmobile owner from
way back and to help us bring you the
Oldsmobile story tonight here is Betty
White
right new happy television star on NBC
and life with Elizabeth and here is
Pablo man when you know bob has been a
representative of Oldsmobile on
television for a long time and speaking
of stars the Starfire Oldsmobile itself
every single male for techne designed
for the future holds no view is years
ahead in every way and you wait'll you
drive it it's even more terrific than it
looks to come along and take the way
the newest owns a rock hammer Amex when
she'll do for longer styling - it's a
rocket store it's a power star it's a
drink order
see that dream car Oldsmobile tomorrow
at your dealers big spring showing and
you drive it - there's never been
anything like
well we're back in the theater this is
getting so exciting even me even the
Oscars have goosebumps that's about all
they've got tomorrow
tomorrow they'll be engraved with the
names of the winners and who are those
winners well nobody knows except mr.
William Miller mr. Miller is a
representative of Price Waterhouse the
accounting firm that tabulates the votes
cast by nearly 2,000 the Claddagh me
members mr. Miller now let's get to the
big moment number one and bring someone
on stage to present the Academy Awards
for distinctive achievement in
documentary productions Elizabeth Taylor
and Michael Wilding
there was nominated for documentary
production short subjects are the
Alaskan Eskimo Walt Disney RKO radio
Walt Disney producer the living City
encyclopedia britannica films john
barnes producer operation blue jay
United States Army Signal Corps they
planted a stone worldwide pictures
British information centres James Carr
produces the word 20th Century Fox John
Healy and John Adams produces and the
winner is mr. Wiley mrs. Riley the
Alaskan Eskimo Walt Disney Productions
RKO radio Walt Disney
nominated for documentary feature
production are the conquest of Everest
countryman films British United Artists
John Taylor Leon klore and Graham
thought produces the living deserts
Walt Disney Buena Vista distributors
Walt Disney producer a queen is crown
junior rank organization British
universal international castle tonight
producer and the winner is mr. Walden
this is Larry the Living Desert
well I tell you isn't she beautiful I
don't know what she sees in him well
well or will it upward with the Arts to
present the award for the best
achievement by a studio sound Department
the Academy has invited a gentleman
associated with the most famous sound of
the year Jack Webb
dig that crazy uniformity
don't be silly these are police fatigues
for the best achievement by a studio
sound Department the nominations are
Calamity Jane Warner Brothers William a
Muir From Here to Eternity Columbia John
Peel Emma Derry knights of the round
table metro-goldwyn-mayer British aw
Watkins the Mississippi gambler
universal international Leslie I carry
and the War of the Worlds paramount
Lauren L Ryder the winner please From
Here to Eternity Columbia John Peel of
Adara